bonjour Sarah el hairy bonjour
secrétaire d'État chargé de la jeunesse
et du service national universel merci
d'être de retour parmi nous puisque vous
étiez ici il y a un an vous connaissez
la maison vous allez être interviewé par
trois journalistes dans deux de nos
régions je voulais présente tout de
suite à commencer par Claire stanleyn de
retour parmi nous qui représente le
Télégramme et donc la Bretagne la région
Bretagne bonjour Claire on lit jusqu'à
Nantes bien sûr on va en reparler tout à
l'heure également de retour parmi nous
Fabrice wesser Redon secrétaire général
de la rédaction parisienne du groupe
Ebra qui représente les grands journaux
du Grand Est il y en a une dizaine au
moins le progrès l'Alsace etc bonjour
Fabrice et puis également de retour
parmi nous contre un calmer journaliste
politique a publique Sénat que vous
connaissez aussi sans doute alors ici
parmi les petites traditions et là il y
a la le questionnaire de Proust et c'est
clair qui commence par la première
question à vous poser pour savoir plus
sur vous oui je me demandais moi quelle
était la personnalité féminine qui avait
pu vous inspirer dans votre carrière
dans votre enfance c'est et pour quelle
raison tu sais on a toujours des rôles
modèles qui sont familiaux moi
évidemment j'ai énormément de
d'admiration pour ma mère pour ma
grand-mère mais en ce moment je sais que
ça peut faire un peu basique de le dire
mais Simone Veil pour le pour plusieurs
raisons exactement en fait j'ai vu le
film j'ai même invité ma mère à aller le
voir le weekend d'après mais au-delà
au-delà du film on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui finalement son combat alors
loin de chez nous d'abord avec les
États-Unis qui remettent en question
l'IVG ensuite j'ai été partiellement
touchée de voir la relation dans le film
avec sa sœur que j'avais peut-être moins
perçu dans nos livres d'histoire en tout
cas moi ça m'a pris au tripes et puis je
pense aussi à un moment où dans au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée nationale se pose cette
question de est-ce que le droit à l'IVG
doit être doit être constitutionnel ça
veut dire que finalement son combat à
elle il est très contemporain et très
d'actualité alors je sais que c'est
celle qu'on nomme et qu'on cite parfois
par facilité mais là pour le coup pour
moi je pense que c'est un sens
particulier d'ailleurs le film a un
énorme succès moi j'ai adoré tous ceux
qui l'ont pas vu je les invite vraiment
à le voir parce du combat d'une femme ça
montre à quel point la dignité humaine
parce que c'est qu'on voyait plusieurs
combats et est un essentiel allez
Fabrice deuxième question moi je
m'interrogeais on a une on a tous une
citation ou une expression un petit
rythme un peu ou notre quotidien ou
notre vie vous en avez nous oui on a une
que je dis assez souvent c'est la chance
ça aide parfois le travail toujours et
ça c'est un truc pareil un peu de ma
grand-mère mais dans le fond travailler
essayer persévérer c'est aussi une
valeur et dans le fond moi j'ai pas
envie de laisser ma vie ou le
l'éducation des enfants au hasard ou à
la chance et donc je crois que c'est un
engagement très personnel qu'il faut
avoir c'est la valeur travail aussi le
travail dans un moment où tout le monde
se questionne dessus qu'est-ce que ça
signifie donc moi ça me parle en tout
cas c'est ce que je dis je sais pas qui
a inventé ça ou qui l'a dit je crois que
c'est un adage populaire mais pour moi
il a du sens et la loi travail aussi
elle est Quentin la question
public c'est une loi emblématique à
laquelle vous pensez régulièrement que
j'ai majeur
il y en a une moi qui me touche parce
que parce que j'ai grandi au Maroc et
que je suis aussi l'enfant d'une
première génération d'immigration mais
deux parents sont Marocains c'est la loi
de 1905 c'est la loi qui est instaure
dans notre pays la laïcité donc cette
séparation entre les Églises et l'État
mais je peux pas le la mettre toute
seule parce que je suis obligé un peu de
la conjuguer avec la loi 1901 celle qui
permet qui permet le monde associatif
qui permet l'association et dans le fond
la cohésion nationale et la cohésion
sociale pour moi passe par ces deux
grands fondamentaux alors pour le coup
c'est pas notre majorité qui les a
faites nouveautés mais je crois que ce
sont des petites trésors français qu'il
faut préserver et on termine par ma
petite question rituelle votre région de
prédilection votre ville de prédilection
c'est non vous en aviez déjà parlé la
dernière fois tu as commencé en France
parce qu'avant c'était effectivement le
Maroc exactement je suis une nantaise et
dans le fond c'est une ville dans
laquelle j'ai décidé d'en créer mes
racines parce que je suis né dans le
Loir-et-Cher et d'une certaine manière
j'ai suivi la loi sans le vouloir de
pour passer de Romorantin à Nantes et
entre temps par Casablanca Rabat
Mohammedia bakakaza justement un bac au
lycée lyaute de Casablanca et quand
arrive et que tu as vécu ailleurs et
bien tu te rends compte à quel point on
a de la chance d'être français déjà mais
d'avoir l'école d'avoir des médiathèques
d'avoir l'hôpital d'avoir finalement
aussi des droits humains qu'on défend et
une vie politique dense même si
aujourd'hui c'est fracturé en tout cas
pour certains c'est c'est pollué mais
très fier de cette ville qui m'a adopté
et que du coup dont je suis tombée
amoureuse non allez sans transition vous
connaissez aussi bien les missions on
passe à la question cash et la question
cash c'est Quentin qu'il a pose question
cache Quentin question cache très simple
faut-il relancer le débat autour de
l'uniforme à l'école et au collège vous
savez ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est
un débat sur les tenues vestimentaires
je pense à la à Bahia ou
camisa mais je suis aussi cache que je
crois le l'émission ce qui nous amène à
se poser la question de
plus que le collège qu'est ce que le
lycée qu'est-ce que l'école ce sont pas
des lieux comme les autres et donc
imaginez que on y a toutes les libertés
ce serait faux et donc pour moi
l'uniforme je le pose dans mon
écosystème aujourd'hui quand j'organise
le service national universel il y a un
uniforme et donc c'est une forme et
permet cette cohésion j'avais porté à
l'époque bien
français donc républicaine avec des
polos des tenues de sport bien sûr mais
derrière c'est uniforme du SNU il y a
quoi il y a l'unité le sentiment
d'appartenir à un collectif il y a au
fait le fait de virer les marques de du
débat entre les jeunes et donc venir
gommer peut-être momentanément les
différences sociales mais plus que
jamais c'est une voix c'est un chemin il
y a des établissements qui le font moi
j'ai jamais été opposé je pense que ça
apaise maintenant faut que ce soit des
projets d'établissement qui embarque
tout le monde parce que aujourd'hui dire
l'uniforme est obligatoire au sein du
collège ou du lycée je crois que ça
créerait une polémique sans nom alors
même que ça pourrait apaiser
question un petit peu provocatrice je
vous l'accorde est-ce que c'est pas une
régression est-ce qu'on n'est pas
condamné à régressé finalement sur nos
libertés non si vous considérez que la
régression c'est défendre le fait de ne
pas avoir de signaux ostentatoire au
sein de l'école je crois que c'est
finalement la régression de l'esprit
pourquoi on pose pourquoi on pose la
laïcité pourquoi on est on a autant de
combats pour expliquer ce que c'est
parce que notre nouvelle génération ne
voit pas du tout la laïcité comme un
bouclier de liberté il voit la laïcité
comme quelque chose pour les embêter tu
n'as pas le droit de mettre un voile ou
une kippa tu n'as pas le droit de mettre
une croix au standard et donc finalement
exactement ils vivent comme une
contrainte ça veut dire que nous nous
avons échoué nous avons échoué à
expliquer que la laïcité c'est d'abord
la garantie de l'égalité et encore plus
quand c'est ferme au sein du collège ou
du lycée parce que c'est là où on
grandit et on n'a pas à apprendre en
ayant un regard confessionnel ou même
politique ou même spirituel on n'a pas
besoin de savoir ce que tu crois ou ce
que tu ne crois pas par contre en dehors
de l'école
évidemment il faut garantir sa liberté
et je vais aller un peu plus loin parce
que en ce moment on parlait des femmes
tout à l'heure mais le convoi le combat
des iraniennes quand on voit des
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes c'est malheureusement et très
souvent parfois fondé sur des lois
confessionnelles notre pays il défend la
foi moi je crois en Dieu j'ai aimé cette
main c'est ma conception c'est ma vie
personnelle mais est-ce que ça doit
interagir dans ma décision politique
publique la réponse est NON et moi je ne
veux pas que finalement demain un
enseignant n'est pas la possibilité de
parler de la procréation de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes parce que
dans sa classe il aurait finalement les
confessions plus que des élèves les
élèves c'est des citoyens en devenir et
donc c'est en ça ou c'est la laïcité
c'est une loi de liberté et à nous de
retrouver les mots à nous de retrouver
finalement cette conquête et quand on
aura réussi à montrer que la laïcité
c'est un progrès alors je crois qu'on
aura regagné cette nouvelle génération
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
plus que c'est plus que jamais très
moderne et pas du tout has been et pas
vieux et pas du tout quelque chose qui
prive
on a eu ces 720 atteinte à la laïcité
c'est le chiffre qui est qui est tombé
pour le mois d'octobre c'est beaucoup
lié à des incidents autour de tenues de
port religieuse et donc on en vient à ce
thème de la Baillac et donc ce nouveau
vêtement en forme de robe et game on a
vu qu'effectivement il y avait des
endroits où les jeunes femmes par
provocation et avec des défis TikTok
porter ses vêtements vous pouvez le dire
vous concrètement la Baya est un
vêtement religieux ce qu'on a vu que le
ministre papénia il ne veut pas rentrer
dans ce détail là
le ministapè mdr il est franchement il
est courageux il est courageux il nomme
les choses il dit la loi de il dit que
ça doit être une circulaire du ministère
qui doit dire qu'elle est le vêtement
religieux ou pas mais il a expliqué
pourquoi il explique que finalement un
habit il peut être par destination
religieuse et non dans ce que dans ce
cadre-là oui il faut évidemment punir
d'abord convoqué la famille parce que
c'est facile de tout mettre sur l'école
moi je crois que l'école a tout son rôle
mais bon sang qui sont les grands
démissionnaires dans dans l'histoire ils
sont où les parents ils sont finalement
tous ces acteurs du continuum éducatif
un enfant il part pas de chez lui avec
la tenue qu'il souhaite sans un moment
ou un autre une remarque une attention
et donc moi je vraiment je remets tout
le monde face à ces responsabilités
l'éducation de nos enfants passe d'abord
par l'éducation donnée par leurs parents
et l'école elle instruit elle donne les
moyens de grandir elle éveillent et là
il faut être aux côtés des enseignants
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est la
pression qui est mise il faut être
courageux aujourd'hui pour être pour
être prof dans un collège ou dans un
lycée et aller expliquer que non une
abaya c'est une professionnelle quand en
plus on vient filmer un CPE quand il
vous demande de l'enlever quand on sait
que c'est volontaire de provoquer quitte
à mettre en danger un enseignant c'est
ce que nous voyons avec TikTok
utilise ses vêtements sans les appeler à
Baya effectivement donc c'est facile de
les détourner les utiliser exactement et
en plus à la limite ses vêtements si
votre utilisé des tournées bien sûr que
on est libre de les porter en dehors du
collège de lycée il y a un sanctuaire ce
sanctuaire c'est les lieux où on fait
grandir l'esprit l'esprit critique et
donc c'est en dehors de ces
établissements là c'est toute la liberté
de notre pays on a évidemment le droit
de mettre ce que l'on veut mais pas
partout exactement alors justement
concernant l'école il y avait une
actualité cette semaine c'est le retour
des maths pour la rentrée prochaine ça
veut dire que Jean-Michel Blanquer c'est
trompé finalement elle est remettre les
tomates l'esprit moi je trouve que moi
j'étais avec et aux côtés Jean-Michel
Blanquer son bilan est un est un grand
bilan c'est un ça a été un ministre
courageux sur les questions de Laï sur
même la réforme du bac je me souviens à
quel point ça avait créé du débat alors
même que le nouveau bac est mieux
entendu avec lui qu'avec l'actuel
ministre ah non je m'entends très bien
aussi avec Papy alors même que nous a
prédestiné on nous a aviez pas forcément
les mêmes lignes sur le quiisme
initialement entre c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on a beaucoup lu et je vous assure
que moi j'ai à mes côtés un ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
extrêmement
objectif qui barre qui part débattre et
qui appliquent toutes nos lois et
d'ailleurs j'étais touchée par son
premier déplacement il a été dans
l'école de Samuel Paty c'est lui qui
renforce les équipes des valeurs de la
République et donc moi j'ai d'une
certaine manière je sais que pour une
laïque c'est bizarre de le dire mais il
y a la force du converti dans ses propos
et ça pour moi c'est un vrai mais c'est
un vrai allié est-ce que vous étiez
favorable à cette remise de 1h30 de
maths par semaine oui bien sûr c'est
toujours c'est toujours bon c'est
toujours c'est toujours positif
maintenant on sait que la plus grande
des victoires les maths sont
essentielles et la plus grande des
victoires c'est comment on va demain
faire pour que on apprenne mieux les
maths il y avait 25% des étudiants des
lycéens apparemment qui sont en
difficulté
moi je vous assure moi j'étais de ces
élèves là moi j'ai fait un bac esprit
écho pour avoir un peu moins de matobact
parce que parce que j'avais besoin de
soutien scolaire parce que les mecs les
maths pour le coup terrifiées et j'étais
bon élève et ça veut dire qu'on a
quelque chose quand même à réussir elle
est avant de poursuivre sur la jeunesse
je vous propose de regarder ce condensé
de l'actualité de la semaine vu des
régions et vu par Rosine Pagès
territoire Hebdo c'est maintenant
[Musique]
on va faire plusieurs stations pour
trouver un ou bien pour ne rien trouver
en finale comme un air de déjà-vu file
d'attente rupture à la pompe et les
calculs qui reprennent à en perdre son
arithmétique l'augmentation là elles
vont supprimer la les 10 centimes
c'était 30 centimes de ristourne
monsieur sinon demain c'est 10 centimes
de plus du lit je crois rater 20
centimes de plus mais j'aurais pas fait
la queue effectivement deux heures pour
économiser 5 euros voilà donc là
effectivement comme c'est une voiture
pro je l'ai fait pour faire plaisir à
mon patron d'un dispositif à l'autre une
nouvelle aide gouvernementale et dans
les tuyaux cibler sur les gros rouleurs
[Musique]
des banderoles inédites et une grève à
laquelle on n'est pas vraiment habitué
les labos ont analysé le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
leur résultat est clair il rejette le
budget qui leur est alloué il y a des
économies à faire on les fait on
participe à hauteur de 250 millions
d'euros économie sur un an ce qui est
déjà considérable et là c'est le fait
que ce soit répétitif sur les années
suivantes alors qu'en fin de compte on a
quand même malgré tout à subir la hausse
de tout ce qui est énergétique bien
entendu il va y avoir des
revalorisations salariales si on est en
danger économique il y a des chances
qu'on ferme il y a des risques tout du
moins que l'on ferme ces sites lundi
dernier 95% des laboratoires d'analyses
médicales étaient fermés en France selon
les syndicats de cette profession
un enfer au lieu dit du Paradis envers
orange des abonnés plutôt amer à 20
minutes de Tours plus d'internet ni de
téléphone depuis un mois on est
absolument coupé de toutes les
communications habituelles pour moi ce
qui est plus embêtant c'est la partie
justement internet qui nous prive de
tous les services de connexion
administrative mais qui va donc venir
réparer ce câble adsl sectionné
accidentellement lors de travaux il
attend désormais le sous-traitant du
sous-traitant orange nous intervient
plus eux-mêmes sur leur réseau ils ont
des sous-traitants qui ont des
sous-traitants et on vous répond notre
sous-traitant ne pour intervenir que à
telle date aucune amélioration n'est à
prévoir avant le 24 novembre
et oui qui va venir réparer tous ces
pauvres étudiants aussi on a vu un
retraité mais il y a aussi des étudiants
qui n'ont pas de wifi près de Tours que
peut faire l'état
se bousculer booster essayer mais la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a des
pénuries dans plein de secteurs
d'activités et pour le coup ce qu'on
voit dans leur potage c'est absolument
horrible il suffit d'avoir un seul jour
pas de réseau dans son téléphone et on
voit à quel point ça coupe ça met aussi
en danger de pas pouvoir échanger
prévenir en cas de en cas de besoin je
comprends la je comprends la souffrance
et l'alerte de ces personnes et je pense
que je vais dans la certitude parce que
c'est un homme de conviction et qui est
un vrai bagarreur mais le ministre
Jean-Noël Barrault en charge des
télécommunications et du numérique doit
certainement être déjà en train
d'essayer de trouver des solutions au
plus vite pour répondre à ses besoins
c'est le sujet qui vous a fait le plus
réagir ou plutôt l'essence la prime à
l'essence qui s'est arrêté la grève dans
les labos
vous savez la prime la prime sur
l'essence moi ce que je vois c'est que
il faut être protecteur d'abord et avant
tout parce que dans le fond cette hausse
des prix elle est partout elle est dans
quand on fait nos courses elle est dans
les sens et on a parfois pas le choix et
souvent on n'a pas le choix d'utiliser
sa voiture mais protecteur pour tout le
monde oui protecteur tout le monde mais
ceux qui ont pas forcément besoin qu'on
les aide mais pas tout le temps pour
tout le monde et donc il faut pouvoir
affiner et aujourd'hui c'est le projet
du projet du gouvernement c'est quand il
fallait protéger tout le monde
rapidement on a fait ce choix là c'est
les fameux 30 centimes mais maintenant
il faut qu'on affine c'est à dire qu'il
faut aider ceux qui ont le plus besoin
ceux qui ont besoin de leur voiture pour
aller travailler qui n'ont pas les
moyens les gros rouleurs 1% de la
population qui est énorme et finalement
quand tu as la possibilité d'avoir des
transports en commun que tu travailles à
quelques kilomètres de ton emploi ou si
ton emploi c'était infirmière
indépendante commerciale artisan tu n'as
pas d'autre choix et donc demain se dire
le coup du carburant fait que je ne peux
pas travailler ou je ne peux plus
travailler serait inacceptable et c'est
pour ça que Elisabeth borne l'a
annonçait la première ministre dès le
1er janvier spécifique seront faites
pour ceux qui en ont le plus besoin et
les gros rouleurs en particulier
pendant le reportage et les spectateurs
n'ont pas vu vous étiez assez en colère
ils font grève contre le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
ils vont devoir contribuer au budget de
la Sécu ils sont pas d'accord avec une
grève reconductive c'est ça peut être
très handicapant pour les tarifs en fait
pour les personnes âgées qui sont très
inquiètes aussi pour leurs analyses de
sang etc qu'est-ce que vous ça vous
évoque cette grève très sincèrement je
suis très mal à l'aise avec cette grève
moi je suis une syndicaliste avant
d'être député j'étais responsable
syndicale à la CFTC donc j'ai le goût
j'avoue du des bases syndicales voir
parfois de la contestation c'est aussi
comme ça que je me suis construite mais
toujours avec beaucoup de justesse c'est
pas juste là pour le coup c'est pas
juste pendant le covid ils se sont ultra
mobilisés humainement et le l'État était
a été là on a payé plus les tests payer
plus pour permettre les vaccins c'était
7 milliards de bénéfices l'année
dernière mais chapeau bas parce que
événement ils ont mouillé la chemise
comme personne comme d'ailleurs les
praticiens hospitaliers les pharmaciens
et là l'effort alors même qu'on a trois
mille milliards de déficits l'inflation
elle touche tout le monde tout le monde
fait un effort les familles font des
efforts leur budget leur chiffre
d'affaires c'est de l'argent public
c'est les c'est en réalité la sécurité
sociale et aujourd'hui dans le projet de
loi qui est porté c'est simplement un
effort qui baisserait de 250 millions
c'est à dire eux on baisse une partie du
remboursement leur demande pas
d'injecter des sous c'est on baisse une
partie du remboursement alors même qu'on
a su augmenter pendant la période de
crise et bien quand tu es solidaire
quand tu es responsable dans un moment
comme ça franchement ça peut être bien
de jouer le coup de solidarité c'est
pour ça que voilà j'étais assez à ces
questionné et assez touché par cette
case et les étudiants et les jeunes font
aussi des efforts ils se servent la
ceinture notamment depuis la rentrée et
avec cette inflation qui grimpe de plus
en plus regardez reportages tournés à la
rentrée
la rentrée coûte de plus en plus cher
surtout pour les étudiants toucher eux
aussi par l'inflation il faut donc faire
des compromis c'est de plus en plus dur
au niveau de faire des courses et de
prendre ce que je veux on mange assez
classique on va dire et puis bah pas
tant de sortie que ça au final on fait
plus de concessions entre guillemets on
va moins sortir le soir moins moins
faire de choses après les cours c'est
pas facile
mais on essaye de tenir mais ça veut
dire sur certaines choses on est obligé
de se restreindre ça devient c'est
compliqué quand même l'Association
générale des associations fait le calcul
cette année la rentrée à Tours coûte
4,5% plus cher que l'année dernière
malheureusement les aides ne suivent pas
l'inflation cette année elle n'augmente
que de 4% alors que l'inflexion et de 6%
et c'est très compliqué pour nous de
voir la détresse des étudiants de
proposer des solutions mais qui pour
nous ne sont que palliative une aide
parmi d'autres Emmaüs avec sa semaine
spéciale étudiant ici pour eux c'est à
moitié prix l'occasion pour Maëlys et
Zara de se faire quelques petits
plaisirs c'est vraiment des petits prix
là en plus de de l'offre étudiante c'est
vrai que ça revient à vraiment pas cher
au final donc on est enfin moi je suis
très contente un tarif préférentiel sur
simple présentation de la carte
étudiante c'est la deuxième année de
l'opération pour Emmaüs Touraine
oui c'est de plus en plus difficile avec
cette inflation qui grimpe Fabrice ça
nous rappelle quand même le point de
cancer de Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
l'Assemblée nationale
il a fallu baisser vous avez baissé le
gouvernement baissé les allocations moi
ça me fait penser à autre chose moi ça
me fait plutôt penser parce que là pour
le coup c'était une sorte de coup de pub
volontaire provocateur pour pour titrer
le sujet mais le sujet est là
en tout cas si vous le permettez plutôt
quand on a vu ses étudiants faire la
queue pendant le covid dans les banques
dans les banques alimentaires au resto
du coeur ça ça tord le bide est-ce que
tu dis comment dans un pays comme le
nôtre aussi puissant les plus
vulnérables vers nos enfants et plus
âgés c'est les plus vulnérables se
retrouvent à faire la queue au resto du
coeur pour répondre à cette précarité là
parce qu'elle est elle est réelle ils
sont percutés de la même manière que
toute la France sauf que eux ils sont
plus vulnérables encore et bien les
réponses elles ont été d'urgence d'abord
tu remets tu réponds aux besoins
premiers alimentaires repas 1 euro matin
et soir ça touche tous les boursiers
mais c'est ouvert à tous ceux qui le
demandent et tu attends pas d'envoyer
des dossiers pour le faire c'est
automatique d'abord l'alimentation
ensuite le gel des loyers bien sûr la
revalorisation de la question la
revalorisation des bourses par rapport à
l'inflation mais le coût de la vie reste
plus élevé que des que les réponses et
donc une seule mesure et c'est Sylvie
Retailleau la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur qui le dit le moindre jeune
qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui et qui se
retrouve dans une galère alors même que
il n'est pas boursier il doit pousser la
porte du parce qu'il y a des aides
d'urgence spéciale à cette période de
l'inflation elles peuvent aller jusqu'à
2700 euros maintenant plus globalement
il faut il faut transformer nos bourses
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand tu fais
partie de la classe moyenne et que tu
n'es pas éligible tu n'as rien et donc
ce ça c'est pas acceptable puisque avant
quand les parents pouvaient aider et
qu'aujourd'hui ils peuvent plus il faut
remplir la cuve de fioul il faut faire
enfin bien sûr on a des coûts
supplémentaires alors ces étudiants là
ils doivent pas rester sur le côté donc
nous sommes en train de réformer tout le
système pour qu'il soit plus juste on
parle des jeunes précaires mais on parle
aussi beaucoup en ce moment des jeunes
paraissent qui ont la flemme alors oui
nous on a fait un quartier sur le monde
du travail ce que révèle la démission
silencieuse et c'est vrai qu'on est la
grande flemme et la grande flemme et on
voit qu'effectivement il y a de plus en
plus de jeunes de désengagements dans
l'entreprise le fait de ne plus vouloir
se définir uniquement par son travail et
du coup effectivement
la valeur travail dont on parlait tout à
l'heure qui perd quand même un petit peu
de de son de son côté central et pivot
dans la vie
je suis pas sur cette ligne là je suis
plutôt
bien on a une question mobile qui vient
de Bretagne
ce que vous venez de dire on l'écoute ça
vient des Côtes-d'Armor bonjour je suis
Nathalie thoravage je suis chef d'une
petite entreprise artisanale de
charcuterie traiteur avec un effectif de
d'une dizaine de salariés nous sommes
situés à Lannion dans les Côtes-d'Armor
et mon interrogation se porte sur un sur
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui est un
sujet récurrent entre employeur
lorsque je passe une annonce pour
recruter une personne en CDI à 35 heures
nos diplômés sans expérience car je
forme
et que lorsqu'un candidat se présente
qui trouve les conditions de travail et
les postes intéressants finit quand même
par m'expliquer qu'après calcul il est
toujours plus intéressant pour lui de ne
pas accepter le poste parce que il est
mieux rémunéré par les assédics et donc
d'où ma question comment comment
pouvez-vous inciter ces chômeurs à
accepter de reprendre des des emplois
avant la fin de leurs droits
alors là cette question concrète
la location chômage et c'est ce que nous
avons fait avec Olivier du soft parce
que aujourd'hui ce qui est encore plus
inacceptable c'est dire je suis plus
confortable à être en situation où je
touche une allocation chômage que si je
suis au travail en réforme la longueur
ou on réforme le montant non on réforme
les deux en réalité en prenant
considération la réalité du marché du
travail aujourd'hui on a marché de
travail qui est extrêmement dynamique on
a plein d'emplois
d'engagement jeune exactement
c'est la valeur travail donc ça
s'adresse à des jeunes sans formation
sans emploi ce dont on parle qui ont
moins de 26 ans et qui peuvent
bénéficier donc d'une aide de 500 euros
par mois sous réserve qui travaille
entre 15 et 20 heures
par mois par semaine alors quel est le
bilan de de cette proposition le bilan
est une réussite pourquoi on a créé le
contrat d'engagement jeune on nous avait
mis face à la question RSA pour les
jeunes ou pas c'est ça le débat initial
nous moi je crois et je rappelle qu'il y
a quand même
1,5 millions de jeunes qui sont sans
emploi et je crois qu'il y a 178 000
bénéficiaires de votre centrage 18000
bénéficiaires depuis sa création donc
depuis mars dernier mais ça veut dire
quoi nous on croit que le travail
émancipe par contre un jeune qui est en
situation de précarité on ne le laisse
pas dans la galère dire qu'on le ferme
pas les yeux non plus et donc c'est du
donnant-donnant c'est aussi ça le goût
de l'effort c'est aussi ça la
persévérance et là jeune femme qui
disait moi je n'arrive pas à recruter en
réalité les jeunes ils demandent deux
choses un évidemment la période n'est
pas la grande démission moi j'aime
appeler ça la grande négociation ils
veulent du sens ils veulent
effectivement de l'organisation plus
flexible mais ils veulent aussi d'une
certaine manière la capacité de projeter
et donc des entreprises qui recrutent
sans CV c'est aussi très bien sans CB
parce qu'il y a des jeunes qui parfois
n'ont rien à écrire sur leur CV et de
l'autre côté aller chercher la capacité
d'avoir confiance en l'autre et lever
quelques freins et on fait le contrat
d'engagement jeune c'est que parce qu'il
des jeunes qui ne peuvent pas postuler
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le permis de
conduire alors vaut mieux qu'ils
viennent qui passent il y a des jeunes
qui retournent à l'emploi justement ça
commence il est énorme c'est pour le
coup une réussite en ça c'est un
investissement mais comme
l'apprentissage le meilleur chemin pour
l'emploi 700000 apprentis cette année
c'est le fruit de réforme successives ça
a été porté par la première ministre
avec un jeune solution le travail c'est
ce qui permet de gagner sa liberté et de
s'émanciper parfois on a besoin d'un peu
plus de valeur et c'est le cas avec le
contrat d'engagement jeune votre projet
faire en direction de la jeunesse le
service national universel universel
ministère exactement c'est bien la
mission qu'on vous a fixée lorsque vous
avez repris des fonctions dans le
gouvernement le SNU depuis mi-octobre
les jeunes de 15 à 17 ans peuvent à
nouveau s'inscrire pour l'année
prochaine 32000 jeunes avaient participé
au SMU elle a les dernières là cette
année a pas de place hein c'est limité
le nombre de places l'idée c'est quoi
c'est que ce soit obligatoire bientôt
fais-moi la musique
aujourd'hui c'est le volontariat ce que
la mission du président de la République
a été très claire il l'a dit le 13
juillet dernier dans son discours à
l'Hôtel de Brienne il faut aller
chercher la généralisation il faut aller
il a rappelé à Toulon il fera des
annonces pendant qu'il présentait la
revue des armées il a fait des annonces
en disant que il reviendra sur le SMIC
dans quelques semaines donc je
n'annoncerai pas avant lui il est
obligatoire c'est vous qui avez dit ça
moi je pense que c'est une bonne c'est
une bonne horizon je vous assure que
quand c'est le présent de la République
qui doit s'exprimer c'est présent
d'arriver est-ce qu'il faudra en passer
par une loi est-ce que vous irez au
Parlement de fait un projet comme
celui-là faut dire ce que c'est c'est un
projet de société univers tous les
jeunes de 15 à 16 ans quelque chose de
plus patriotique aussi j'imagine que ça
fait aussi partie de de
remettre des valeurs le projet du SNU
c'est quand je dis c'est un projet de
société il doit répondre à plusieurs
besoins c'est c'est de la cohésion
nationale c'est de la cohésion sociale
c'est le goût de l'effort c'est de la
rencontre vraiment de la mixité des
jeunes d'auréac des jeunes de Nantes
oui aussi parce qu'il y a des tests
d'illettrisme dedans mais aussi des
bilans de santé parce que on a plein de
dans notre pays qui n'ont pas vu de
médecins et qui sont du coin décrochage
revenir à des essentiels je sais que ça
peut faire sourire mais faire son lit se
lever
prendre le temps de rencontrer quelqu'un
de différent mais aussi se rendre compte
que dans notre pays c'est la réserve une
opérationnelle en temps de guerre
écoutez c'est pour permettre d'augmenter
la culture de l'engagement pour ceux qui
choisiront un engagement militaire bien
sûr il le pourront c'est une chance et
c'est une possibilité et pour ceux qui
choisiront le civil ça sera aussi
peut-être rejoindre des mouvements de
solidarité ou le monde de
l'intergénérationnel entre nos
associations parce qu'on a une grande
crise aujourd'hui du bénévolat aussi
mais plus que jamais on aura réussi le
SNU si chaque jeune se dit qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour mon pays que ce soit
dans le civil ou de longues militaire
chacun est libre mais un temps de
cohésion un temps d'effort commun par le
sport une ritualisation aussi peut-être
des rituels républicains ça fait du bien
lever un drapeau chanté la Marseillaise
partie c'est lire la presse locale
[Rires]
sélectionner pour vous qui sont récentes
à vous de nous choisir celle qui vous
inspire le plus alors on a une est
République sur la grippe aviaire qui a
lieu quand même dans toutes les régions
en ce moment on a beaucoup le progrès
qui revient sur la position de Gérard
Collomb et sur ses migrants de la chaîne
victime dont on parle beaucoup quand ta
Costa à Toulon enfin on parle surtout
des mineurs des 26 mineurs qui ont fugué
on peut en reparler le télégramme qui
titres lui sur la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar qui débute comme tout le monde le
sait ce week-end et qui s'interroge et
elle est ou pas d'ailleurs claire la
question éthique elle porte peut-être
là-dessus avant que la ministre répond
alors la réponse moi je veux enfin moi
ce qui me touche le plus c'est le cata
et c'est clair qu'il faut la pose
exactement c'est ce que disait c'est
dans le titre d'ailleurs de notre
quotidien y aller ou pas pour les
supporters c'est une vraie question
est-ce que maintenant que la Coupe du
monde ouvre effectivement dimanche
est-ce qu'ils vont boycotter tout seul
est-ce qu'ils vont boycotter en groupe
ou est-ce que finalement tout le monde
va regarder vous savez ce que je
souhaite c'est que l'équipe française
revienne avec une troisième étoile
c'est clair
nous on a gagné la Coupe de France le FC
Nantes a gagné la Coupe de France et
donc du coup je me dis si on gagne la
Coupe de France et que en plus on a la
troisième étoile ça sera une réussite
par contre ça veut pas dire nier le
débat autour de la question du Qatar
bien sûr il faut pas le nier les
questions de droit de droit LGBT des
gaïdes entre les femmes et les hommes de
la manière dont les travailleurs sont
accompagnent tout ça évidemment il faut
le traiter le sport contrairement à ce
qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron
le sujet il est là en fait le sport
c'est d'abord un vecteur je crois encore
de d'unité dans notre pays si demain on
ramène la Coupe du Monde on sera uni
est-ce que
ça n'importe où ça veut dire non on est
responsable de nos choix d'accord tout
le monde est responsable de ses choix
par contre le choix il a été fait il y a
12 ans personne n'était pas en
responsabilité à ce moment-là et je
pense que tous les esprits n'étaient pas
aussi aiguisés et veillées à ces sujets
du
Qatar était bon vous dites non pas trop
sincèrement non moi je pense que à
l'aune de ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui la
question c'est moi je moi j'aime les
pays qui sont qui sont en pleine
acquisition de de droits qui défendent
ces libertés on est un pays
universaliste c'est-à-dire que nos
valeurs rayonnent au-delà de nos
frontières c'est ça être français c'est
un esprit c'est un génie si on dit c'est
un débat mais là
c'est la faute de ceux qui ont décidé à
l'époque par contre notre job et le job
de notre équipe de France c'est de
d'abord de répondre à cette d'aller
chercher cette troisième étoile et notre
job en langue politique c'est de
continuer et bien par la diplomatie et
bien d'aller chercher le soutien de ces
ONG le soutien aujourd'hui des combats
partout dans le monde que ce soit au
Qatar en Iran enfin partout peut-être
mieux choisir les pays dans lesquels par
contre ne pas ne pas faire culpabiliser
ceux qui aiment le foot parce qu'ils
regardent le match quoi c'est pas le
sujet voilà
les joueurs de l'équipe de France
portent un brassard c'est le le c'est la
question aujourd'hui peut-être que les
jeunes qui regardent la coupe aurait
comme ça le sentiment qui il se passe
quelque chose sur le terrain peut-être
favorable
il a parlé un petit peu vite en tout cas
je pense qu'il a parlé en son intime
conviction en son nom ce qui est certain
c'est que ce que j'aime dans le sport
au-delà de l'esprit de cohésion et le
fait que ça transporte c'est que ça
respecte des règles il y a des règles et
quand on est sur un terrain on respecte
les règles et au la règle c'est quoi
c'est la FIFA dessine et les équipes
portent ou pas le brassard donc la
responsabilité aujourd'hui elle dépend
de la FIFA dit oui vous dites il faut
que les joueurs français portent un
brassard
j'étais député donc quand on fait quand
on fait la loi on aime que ce qu'on a
voté ou ce qu'on a pensé s'applique et
bien de la même manière quand on délègue
à une instance non la FIFA c'est
possible après les gens le feraient ou
pas
très sincèrement moi je veux que la FIFA
s'exprime après à titre plus personnel
je crois que il faut porter nos valeurs
de manière fine et intelligente mais
l'égalité est un vrai combat donc le
portée pourquoi pas mais le plus
important c'est d'abord de respecter les
règles et les règles et le process c'est
la FIFA s'exprime et ensuite l'équipe
fait
revenons aussi sur le sort de ces
migrants dont on parle beaucoup de
lotion victime lotion Viking victime
qui va en parler mieux que moi avec
cette une du progrès notamment
oui alors on a pas l'antenne j'aurais
voulu la montrer à la maison
que bon vous avez vu
des premiers soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron
là aujourd'hui il est en contradiction
il dit sur les migration on n'a pas pris
des choses en main pas assez tôt et
encore moi aujourd'hui
je comprends l'alerte je l'entends parce
que parce que nous on a enfin pour moi
l'immigration c'est pas un tabou j'en
suis le fruit c'est pas un tabou on peut
se dire les choses on doit pouvoir se
dire les choses si on veut pas
d'ailleurs que l'extrême droite face
exactement je suis très à l'aise avec ça
est-ce que on a vocation à accueillir
tout le monde de manière
inconditionnelle la réponse est non et
c'est ça est-ce qu'on doit respecter le
droit international bien sûr est-ce que
l'Océanique est une situation
particulièrement exceptionnelle la
réponse est oui on avait un gouvernement
qu'on connaît pas très bien qui venait
d'être l'appel de l'Italie
non parce que parce que aujourd'hui on a
le ministre de l'Intérieur ministère
qu'il connaît très bien avec un ministre
qui est très allant qui aujourd'hui
renforce les auditef se donne les moyens
même avec des des pays amis d'aller
chercher des retours et des laisser
passer consulaires mais là où il faut
pas là il faut pas être naïve quand même
44 26 mineurs isolés sur les 44 qui
avait été sec dans le chêne Viking on
quitté les structures d'accueil Marine
Le Pen parle de l'affaire léonarda
d'Emmanuel Macron et de Gérald Darmanin
c'est c'est grave ce qui s'est passé
avec séminaire isolé tout ce qui est
excessif franchement n'a peut n'a que
peu d'intérêts ces propos sont excessifs
la faire Léonardo c'était autre chose
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça fait plaisir
quand on voit des jeunes finalement
s'échapper entre guillemets enfin ou
partir alors qu'ils n'ont pas été oublié
de ces migrants et de ses rescapés
notamment le niveau des juges qui ont
traité les demandes on voit qu'il y a
des il y a des problèmes avec les
procédures le gouvernement était à la
hauteur sur l'accueil vont pouvoir aussi
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que on est
pas laissé mourir ces personnes ça c'est
le premier point par contre on prend de
la hauteur à boire que ces jeunes et en
réalité un titre permettant qui puisse
aller dans les pays qui doivent les
accueillir et dans les dans lesquels il
souhaitent aller c'est ça en réalité la
victoire la question c'est si ce sont
échappé parce que c'est ça en fait ils
sont partis mais ils sont pas partis en
dessous de la fenêtre enfin ils sont
meilleurs
ils ont pris leur chemin la réalité
c'est que ils sont plus en danger en
faisant ça quand en étant accompagné
c'est ça c'est ça le sujet parce que
quand ils étaient accompagnés ils
avaient un logement de la nourriture des
adultes qui les protègent aujourd'hui
ils sont sur la route peut-être demain à
la main de pasteur mais c'est pas ça que
j'en veux retenir ils étaient déjà un
peu frileux les Français d'accueillir
effectivement ce qui était autour de
l'accueil des migrants s'ils savent
qu'en plus les jeunes ils sont partis
ils veulent pas rester à Toulon ils
veulent aller en Allemagne ils veulent
aller en Suède mais notre sujet il est
pas là notre sujet il est comment on
pose la question de l'immigration et de
nos frontières européennes et nationales
comment faire respecter ses règles la
réalité c'est que si on s'envoie la
patate chose entre nous la Grèce et
l'Italie on n'aura pas de réponse la
vérité c'est que à l'époque Marielle de
sarnaise malheureusement qui nous a
avait quitté a fait un rapport sur les
dublinets la convention de Dublin qui
pose la règle des d'immigration et donc
oui il nous faut une immigration qui qui
est accompagnée mais avec des titres et
puis il faut qu'on accompagne les gens
qui n'ont rien à faire chez nous de
manière plus facile aujourd'hui on a
énormément de mal c'est la réalité pour
plein de raisons mais la volonté là bien
sûr et ceux qui disent c'est facile il y
a une baguette magique carafocon pour le
coup c'est des prêcheurs plus de colère
qu'autre chose c'est que il y a de la
volonté maintenant il y a de l'évolution
législative et c'est tout le sens de la
loi qui est porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur un autre un grand débat un
autre débat contiendra peut-être ici sur
extra local merci beaucoup madame la
ministre merci